- [Audience Member] So not being Gary V,
how can I sort of inspire people around me
to work on their excuses?
- You know, it's funny.
Long before I was Gary V,
this is what I was doing
for my high school friends who were doing
stupid things like drugs and alcohol
or driving drunk because
they wanted to act cool
in front of somebody.
This is just about self-esteem.
It's so simple it's almost
overly emotional for me.
This is about self-esteem.
The way I choose to do it,
and you know this is how I do it,
is I go directly at it.
Everyone one of us can think
of somebody we care about
right now that's just not doing it right
and all you have to do is sit them down
and tell them they're not doing it right
but we don't want to do that
because we'd rather not
short-term hurt their feelings
and let them fail long-term
which is remarkably crazy
if you give a (bleep) about somebody.
So what can you do as not Gary V?
Have the actual conversation
and tell you sister, your
mom, your uncle, your aunt,
your child, your best
friend the next time they
come up with an excuse,
that it's a (bleep) excuse.
The reason I say the thing
that if there's anybody
that ever looked like you that made it,
then there's no excuse
is 'cause I believe it.
It's really hard, you're in an argument
and your friend tells
you that's great Gary,
but both my parents were alcoholics
and that really (bleep) me up.
Right now you're on the defense,
that's a good first punch by them.
I'm like, cool, we don't need to use me
if anybody has ever been successful
that had two alcoholic parents
which, by the way, I know of three,
well then, now what's your excuse Karen?
We are just so interested
in blaming everybody else
and excuses 'cause we don't
want to take on responsibility
and somewhere a long time
ago I went completely
I only, you know, I think
everything is my fault?
Like all of it.
I think it's weirdly
cloudy outside right now
and not nice out, my fault.
His scar, my fault, I (bleep)
just default into my fault
and everybody tries to do
everything else the other way.
And let me tell you how good life becomes
when you take on responsibility.
It gets real good.
Some of you, and there's a
lot of you that follow me,
you know why I keep bringing it up,
the last scene of Eight
Mile, the M and M movie?
How many people have seen that movie?
Great.
The last scene, they go into the battle,
he makes fun of himself the whole time
because it leaves the
other person with nothing.
The leverage is in being
accountable of everything.
The leverage is exposing your weaknesses.
I proudly talk about
passing on Uber twice,
being a D and F student.
I proudly talk about my shortcomings.
I can't wait for more
bad things to happen.
I mean it.
Because I will talk about them
because, what, you're so (bleep) perfect?
(bleep) you.
Right?
So how do you do it?
You have the conversation and you realize
that you're doing a
disservice to the people
you love the most by
holding your mouth shut
because you're not willing to deal
with the short-term conflict.
(audience clapping)